bonjour à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur public sénat pour suivre
et bien la suite des auditions menées
par la commission d' enquête sur
l'éducation et la perte de repères
républicain ici au sénat pour vous
resituer cette commission denquête elle
a été créée à la demande du groupe ump à
la fin du mois de janvier au lendemain
d'attentats meurtriers qui ont frappé la
france
son but répondre à cette question
comment faire pour faire de l'éducation
le creuset des valeurs de la république
et lutter contre les difficultés
rencontrées par les enseignants dans
l'exercice de leur métier
cette commission denquête auditionné ce
matin laurent bigorgne président du
think tank libéral
l'institut montaigne laurent bigorgne
est revenu devant les sénateurs sur sa
vision du système éducatif français
et il a insisté sur le fait que
l'éducation est un remède anti crise on
découvre tout de suite en audition son
diagnostic et ses propositions nous
débutons aujourd'hui nos auditions en
recevant donc monsieur laurent bigorgne
directeur général de l'institut
montaigne comme le bureau de la
commission denquête l'a décidé cette
audition sera capté et diffusé en direct
sur le site internet du sénat et elle
fera également l'objet d'un compte rendu
publié dans le recueil des travaux de la
commission des commissions accessible en
version papier sur le site internet du
thin donc diplômé de l'institut d'études
politiques de paris est agrégé distincts
vous avez occupé différemment différents
postes de direction à sciences po paris
en 2008 vous êtes détaché auprès de la
london school of economics
avant de devenir directeur des études
puis directeur général de l'institut
montaigne en novembre 2010
créée en 2010 l'institut montaigne un
think tank français dont la vocation est
d'élaborer des propositions concrètes
dans les domaines de l'action publique
et de la cohésion sociale notamment en
2011 l'institut montaigne a publié les
résultats d'une enquête approfondie
alizée auprès des habitants de
clichy-sous-bois et de montfermeil en
seine-saint-denis
dans cet ouvrage intitulé banlieue de la
république vous mettiez notamment en
exergue le rôle fondamental de l'école
dans ces quartiers la commission a
souhaité vous entendre pour recueillir
votre analyse des difficultés
rencontrées par l'école dans sa mission
transmission des valeurs républicaines
ainsi que celle des enseignants dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions vous
pourrez sans doute éclairer nos travaux
sur des solutions à mettre en oeuvre
pour rétablir l'école dans sa mission
d'intégration et de formation de futurs
citoyens
avant de vous passer la parole le
formalisme des commission denquête me
conduit à vous demander de prêter
serment
je suis également tenus de vous indiquer
que tout faux témoignage devant notre
commission serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 à 434 15 du
code pénal en conséquent je vous invite
à prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et des jeunes joueurs le jure selon l'
usage habituel je vous propose de nous
faire part de vos observations dure une
quinzaine de minutes après quoi notre à
porter pour pourra vous posez ces
questions je vous remercie madame la
présidente ça profite je commencerai ce
propos rapide en indiquant qu' une forme
de paradoxe à me trouver ici au sénat ce
matin et ce paradoxe s'inscrit dans la
longue durée
au fond un observateur étranger distant
de nos débats domestique distant de nos
institutions marquerait de l'étonnement
a constaté qu'en 2015
nous revenons exactement peu près au
point où nous avait laissé les
évènements de l'automne 2005 et ce
paradoxe vient de ce que ce visiteur
étranger s'interrogerait sur ce que nous
avons fait pendant ces dix ans sur ce
que nous n'avons pas fait pendant ces
dix ans sur ce que nous avons mal fait
pendant ces dix années
will paradoxe le paradoxe c'est que
cette similarité ce sentiment de
répétition c'est insupportable entre
2005 et 2015 est au fond assez normal il
est assez normal dès lors qu'on accepte
la logique qui consiste à regarder ce
que sont les grands indicateurs du
tableau de bord de l'êta de la jeunesse
de notre pays
premièrement si on regarde à la fois des
indicateurs produits nationalement dans
le cadre du service public par l'adep
hockey au fond d'une cellule éducation
nationale si on croise ses données sur
les performances de notre système
scolaire avec les données produites par
l'université de boston dans le cadre de
ce qu'on appelle prince qui est
programme sur l'évaluation des
acquisitions à 9 ans
si on regarde le programme que vous
connaissez bien des acquisitions à 15
ans ce guide ocde bizarre on se rend
compte au final qu'en 15 ans
particulièrement ces dernières années
notre système est devenu éducatif
toujours moins performants toujours plus
inégalitaire
je rappelle à votre assemblée que mes
résultats en classe de 6e ça a été
montré par un sociologue réputée son
meilleur prédicteur de la délinquance
premier point deuxième point toujours en
regardant ou en examinant les politiques
publiques et en s'interrogeant sur les
causes qui font que rien n'a changé
entre 2005 et 2015 la situation
dramatique de l'apprentissage des moins
qualifiés qui est une politique publique
en déshérence et si je regarde ces deux
dernières années et chute des entrées en
apprentissage des jeunes les moins
qualifiés
je ne peux pas dire que nous sommes
donnés collectivement les moyens de
réussir cette politique publique
si je regarde maintenant le taux de
chômage des jeunes depuis 2008 je ne
peux que constater son augmentation très
forte dans notre pays beaucoup plus
forte que chez la plupart de nos voisins
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui nos taux de
chômage moyen des jeunes est en gros
deux fois même deux fois et demie
désormais celui de la population active
ces faibles performances je me dise je
le disais je l'illustrait s'agissant des
performances d'éducation s'accompagne de
fortes inégalités
aux politiques publiques non seulement
ne sont pas performantes mais en plus
elles sont d'une certaine façon dans
leurs résultats parfois dans leur
organisation contraire au principe
d'égalité et qui évidemment fondent
comme d'autres pillées notre république
au final ayant dit tous cas je constate
que notre pays au moment d'entrer dans
la question que vous nous proposez
d'aborder cumulent cinq caractéristiques
et qui est sans doute le seul en europe
peut être le seul dans nos séries
cumulés la première de ces
caractéristiques c'est donc un système
éducatif
peu performant et qui fige assez tôt le
destin scolaire la trajectoire future de
ses élèves
la deuxième de ses caractéristiques
c'est qu'aucun dispositif public privé
aucun dispositif social ne parvient à
récupérer l'échec scolaire et que le
maigre figues et d'apprentissage
concerne je le disais tout à l'heure de
moins en moins de jeunes non qualifiés
la troisième c'est que notre système de
formation professionnelle celui des
adultes est relativement déficient
dès lors qu'il s'agirait de concentrer
d'intervention notamment l'intervention
des moyens publics sur ceux qui en ont
le plus besoin
quatrième caractéristique notre
démographie et rend cela nous sommes
assez singulier en europe est
relativement dynamique ce qui veut dire
que nous envoyons au fond offrons des
échecs de l'échec scolaire puis l'échec
social des échecs professionnels un
nombre toujours plus important de jeunes
je ferai un petit calcul démographique
devant vous pour me montrer dans un
instant 5e caractéristiques nous sommes
un pays de tradition migratoire mauvais
système éducatif en tout cas mauvaises
performances pardon je corrige du
système éducatif système d'apprentissage
en déshérence formation professionnelle
qui ne parvient pas à corriger ses
premières années galite et démographie
dynamique immigration relativement
importante
voilà au fond les cinq piliers d'une
vaste bombe à retardement
pourquoi je disais qu'on peut faire un
calcul démographique assez simple
prenons la tranche des 15 29 ans donc il
va tranche statistiques que l'on repère
on peut considérer que donc sur une
génération de cette tranche sont
produits chaque année en gros cent
cinquante mille jeunes vous savez qui
sortent du système sans diplôme à l'âge
de 16 ans
quinze fois 150 milles c'est en gros sur
une génération un stock de 2 millions
250 mille individus si je prends la note
du cee du conseil d'analysé économique
sur les jeunes qui datent d'il ya deux
ans on constate qu'en france il ya en
gros 2 millions nets dire de gamins qui
ne sont ni en emploi ni information ni à
l'école
ce qui veut dire que dans le meilleur
des cas sur une génération sur un stock
de deux millions deux cent cinquante
on sait en mettre 250 milles au travail
on sait faire avoir une vie sociale
économique normale en gros à 10% de ces
individus voilà qui est notre niveau de
performance d'inclusion au moment où au
fond la vérité par ailleurs au moment où
on passe du système scolaire au système
au système qui ravit à l'emploi d'où
vient ce problème je crois qu'il ya
plusieurs caractéristiques il faudra
près ici au sénat
premièrement nos politiques publiques
sont conduites sans continuité
combien de ministres de l'éducation
nationale sur une décennie
combien de directeurs généraux de
l'enseignement scolaire qu'on ne vienne
pas dire aux citoyens qu'il ya
continuité dans le service public
qu'on ne vienne pas dire aux citoyens
qu'il ya continuité de l'effort
continuité de la vision votre commission
établie sur le terrain elle aura vu des
enseignants je pense que même ce serait
bien en peine depuis 2007 de fait
remarquer régis des différents
dispositifs de remédiation qui leur ont
été proposés à peu près à chaque rentrée
de façon à la fois souvent sous
financées sous exécuté pas évanouie donc
une absence de continuité dans les
politiques publiques des fondements
ces politiques publiques jamais
renouvelé à la fois un assez grand
mépris je me dis tel que je le pense de
la haute administration pour mes acquis
de la recherche une assez forte
indifférence à ce que peut dire par
exemple en éducation en psychologie
cognitive à ce que les économistes du
travail peuvent dire on sait tous
c'est un fait objective et que le fait
d'avoir un prix administrés pour
l'emploi des moins qualifiés est
objectivement un facteur
extraordinairement explicative de la
situation du marché de l'emploi à point
un chat un chat le fait de ne pas avoir
de smic
le prix d'entrée sur le marché du
travail pour les jeunes les moins
qualifiés et une trappe à chômage et
c'est une trappe durable on le sait
cette objectivée par des dizaines
d'articles des meilleurs économistes du
monde produit à peu près d'entourer pays
doit céder il n'en reste pas moins que
jamais ce débat vous m'entendez jamais
ce débat n'est abordée au final on se
fait plaisir et au final
évidemment ceux qui en payent le prix
sont assez loin de nos préoccupations
donc des fondements de politiques
publiques jamais renouvelé ni dans leur
sous bassement théorique ni évidemment
dans leur mise en oeuvre
quand je pointerais mise en oeuvre je
pointe l'absence quasiment totale
d'évaluation de nos politiques publiques
je me dis c'est vrai de rééducation
c'est vrai de l'apprentissage c'est vrai
de la formation professionnelle et même
quand on vient évaluer on n'en tient pas
compte
j'en veux pour preuve que et je salue
beaucoup d'action des ministres
éducation nationale il aura fallu
quasiment deux ans pour expliquer à ceux
qui voulaient envers et contre tous et
envers et contre les études de l'adep
changer les programmes de l'école
maternelle de grande section notamment
pour pouvoir les allégés en contenu
cognitif il aura fallu quasiment deux
ans pour expliquer avant même que toute
la science aller dans ce sens pour une
fille qui ne fallait pas le faire que
c'était possiblement eu un facteur
aggravant les inégalités recon qui sont
déjà je lui dis considérable au final
ces difficultés de politiques publiques
font que nous manquons à mon sens d'une
vision systématique jamais nous
n'envisageons l'école et l'emploi comme
au fond à les deux versants d'une même
montagne
jamais nous n'avons de vision
stratégique s'agissant ces deux ces deux
phénomènes
je rappelle au cas où nous aurions
oublié que si nous avons aujourd'hui 11
% de taux de chômage dans la population
active ou qui frappe la population
active de ce pays
les deux tiers au moins de ce chômage
s'explique par un phénomène de sous
qualification ou de non qualification
le programme chômage structurel en
français est d'abord et avant tout un
programme scolaire un problème de
qualification
j'en termine rapidement l'interrogé sur
au fond les voies et moyens
diagnostiques s'agissant des problèmes
rencontrés dans les écoles de notre pays
après le mois de janvier je dirais
premièrement que je n'ai pas la mesure
de ces phénomènes
je ne sais pas nous sommes en train de
parler je n'ai pas de statistiques
j'ai vu comme tout le monde des médias
peut-être que votre assemblée comme
d'autres acteurs dans ce pays parfois
prend à prendre un peu de distance
critique par rapport à ce que disent les
médias je m'intéresserai en revanche
plus volontiers pourquoi pas à la
difficulté d'enseigner aujourd'hui
certaines cyprine dans nos collèges dans
nos lycées mais permettez moi de
remettre au fondement des problèmes que
nous avons rencontrés me sentiment
aujourd'hui ancré dans la population que
riche ans sont inégalement très
inégalement injustement distribué sur le
territoire que ses chansons durablement
structurellement mal distribué sur le
territoire le système scolaire français
donne très peu de chances aux enfants
d'ouvriers
il donne très peu de chances aux enfants
de chômeurs il donne très peu de chances
aux enfants même de la classe moyenne de
pouvoir
au final améliorer leur sort nous sommes
en train je ne peux pas vous en livrer
aujourd'hui résultat mais nous sommes en
train de terminer une vaste étude à
l'institut montaigne qui est un testing
qui s'intéresse aux discriminations à
raison de la religion
je vous dis les discriminations à raison
de la religion sont très fortes dans
notre pays elle touche les musulmans
certes elle touche réjouissent également
n y sont à rebours de toute la pensée on
pourrait avoir consistera dire mais au
fond si ces élèves font leurs preuves à
l'école nous aurons de meilleures
chances ça n'est pas vrai vous dire que
ça n'est pas vrai aujourd'hui quand on
teste des cv protesting de jeunes
musulmans qui ont un parcours ordinaire
et de jeunes musulmans qui ont un
parcours extraordinaire marquée sous
sauna méritocratie d'un bac mention très
bien d'un certain nombre de diplômes
deux stages d'efforts individuels a
compris on se rend compte qu'il n'ya
aucune élasticité je veux dire par là
qu'il n'y a aucune différence
à la fin du jour dans la possibilité de
trouver un emploi soit dans le secteur
privé soit contractuels dans la fonction
publique donc il faut quand même avoir
la mesure de ce que aujourd'hui
par ailleurs nous sommes le seul pays de
nous aider ou il n'y a pas de différence
entre une parcours des immigrés de
première ou de deuxième génération en
matière de résultats scolaires à 15 ans
il ya des contre-exemples la floride par
exemple est parvenu parfaitement à
redresser cette situation
ce qui veut dire qu'il n'y a aucune
espèce de fatalité à floride et un état
assez vaste dans l'état où il ya
beaucoup d'immigration est un état où il
ya beaucoup de pauvreté des zones
urbaines sensibles
on voit donc bien qu'un certain nombre
de pays sont parvenus à corriger un
certain nombre d'états sont parvenus à
corriger ces mécanismes délétère et
évidemment mettant en cause du lien
social
quelles pourraient être les axes de
travail parce que derrière ce tableau
accablant mais qu'il faut quand même
avoir le courage de regarder en face
je pense qu'à trois axes sur lesquels
nous pourrions réfléchir je ne suis pas
venu vous proposer ce matin des cours de
morale laïque dont j'ignore ce que
pourrait être aussi bien le programme
comme la mise en oeuvre et la réception
par un public de 800 mille enseignants
je pense qu'à trois axes de travail si
votre assemblée veut se donner les
moyens d'envoyer des signaux forts
premièrement nous avons contrairement à
ce qui peut être pensé un très grave
problème en matière de gestion des
premiers âges de la vie et
particulièrement de la petite enfance
il est insupportable il est
insupportable que les dispositifs
notamment d'accueil des plus jeunes
enfants soient concentrés dans les zones
urbaines les plus favorisés et il est
insupportable qu'il soit le plus souvent
absents ou très largement insuffisant
des zones urbaines ou des zones rurales
ou des zones périurbaines mais moins
favorisés pourquoi tout simplement parce
que les acquis de la recherche depuis le
milieu des années 60
je vous renvoie programmes abc d'ariane
montre assez bien que des taux
d'encadrement que des interactions
langagière quotidienne répéter multiples
auprès de jeunes enfants sont un bagage
pour ma vie entière pour ans
aux travaux du prix nobel d'économie
james heckman qui a través tracé au fond
la courbe des retours sur investissement
qu'on peut faire on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui les plus gros retours sur
investissement des plus gros retours sur
investissements se font sur le premier
âge de la vie ayant dit cela je ne peux
que m'interroger vous resté interloqué
balbutiements qui le montrent des choix
publics qui ont été fait puisque en gros
nous soufi n'en sont l'école maternelle
en termes de rémunération des maîtres à
hauteur de 20% comme ça n'est pas
suffisant donc faisons aussi s'agissant
écoles primaires nous sommes dans une
meilleure situation s'agissant du
collège mais avec ma nous dira que c'est
moins important et nous / finance ont
glissé à hauteur de 30% par rapport à la
moyenne de nos cd à la salle inversion
de la courbe que je demande aujourd'hui
aux pouvoirs publics ces scènes là il
faut cesser le surfinancement inutile de
l'enseignement scolaire peu importe si
ça des prix au snes et il faut
impérativement puisque nous sommes un
pays qui concentre de la grande
difficulté une immigration assez
importantes financées mieux mais tout
simplement une action ne mettiez le
geste professionnel des enseignants du
premier degré pour la petite enfance
pourrie code
il me paraît important je renvoie aux
travaux du sénateur carle
il me paraît important nécessaire
premier de tenir compte des acquis de la
recherche dans le geste des maîtres
particulièrement l'école maternelle et à
l'école primaire
il est faux de croire il faut accepter
il est même cruel d'accepter qu'au final
c'est une forme de liberté pédagogique
spontanée qui va améliorer les
performances d'un système qui jouit de
cette liberté depuis toujours le système
d'enseignement primaire à la française
est un système de libéro coalisés dans
du service public
pardon d'employer des mots aussi durs
mais c'est la réalité c'est un système
qui peut évaluer c'est un système où n'y
a aucun principe hiérarchique
il n'y a d'ailleurs pas d'objectif est
donc évidemment nos meilleures façons de
ne pas atteindre des objectifs c'est de
ne pas en fixer est en réalité la
science nous dit la psychologie
cognitive d'économie de l'éducation nous
dit aujourd'hui énormément de choses
ce qu'on peut parvenir à atteindre avec
des groupes d'élèves
il ya énormément d'articles qu'ils ont
publiées je renvoie votre assemblée aux
travaux récents de bruno suchaut qui
objective même renault sochaux qui a été
le patron est réduit à dijon qui
objective même le nombre d'heures qu'il
faudrait mettre à disposition nombre
d'heures d'interaction langagière
individuelle d'un enfant d'exercice d'un
enfant donc pour lui permettre d'accéder
à l'écriture il trouve pour nous ce jour
qu'il faut en gros 35 heures sur un
cycle de trois ans et au mieux
aujourd'hui l'école publique met à
disposition de ses élèves une vingtaine
d'heures évidemment si on a que la
moitié des ressources à disposition ont
fait la moitié du chemin
troisième piste la petite enfance écoles
d'apprentissage mais aussi nos choix qui
a été fait au fond de masquer notre
échec sur l'apprentissage des moins
qualifiés à travers une montée en gamme
de l'apprentissage sur l'enseignement
supérieur est un choix qu'on peut
trouver intéressant pour que progressent
à la fois la professionnalisation des
cursus universitaires et qu'en même
temps cette professionnalisation
s'accompagne d'une diversification des
moyens dédiés à l'enseignement supérieur
tellement celui-ci est sous-financé à
nouveau au profit du lycée
d'enseignement secondaire je le redis
c'est une erreur politique c'est une
erreur de politique publique
nous avons impérativement besoin que
s'inverse la courbe des entrées en
apprentissage pour les moins qualifiés
nos élèves ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'ils y préparer ça veut dire que c'est
un dispositif qu'il faut piloter
ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir le courage
d'entamer la somme des réformes qu'on
n'ose jamais abordé qui est celle du
lycée professionnel et conclure et par
là en disant votre commission que la
discimination de crèches de qualité la
dissémination des acquis et des
meilleurs acquis de la recherche
allez comme high tone primaire que comme
maternelle avec évidemment des outils
d'évaluation extraordinaire m'ont serré
la revue complète de notre politique
d'apprentissage sont les trois piliers
qui font que j'espère en 2025
après les travaux 2005 après ce 2015
vous n'aurez plus à vous poser ses
questions ou en tout cas sous un angle
extraordinairement renouvelée qui aura
vu d'ici là dit
et par deux le taux de chômage des
jeunes merci beaucoup
donc je vais donner la parole jacques
grosperrin pour les premières questions
coupe la parole merci président du raid
d'ores et déjà remercier laurent
bigorgne d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et surtout pour le travail
formidable qu'il dirige au sein de et
avec son équipe au sein de l'institut
montaigne parce que nous nous lisons
régulièrement toutes ses publications et
vraiment avec beaucoup d'intérêt et on
sent véritablement qu'il y a
qui est de la recherche il ya des acquis
et puis et surtout des aspects
scientifiques ont réutilisé ce n'est pas
simplement une lecture une écriture de
documents suite à des difficultés qu on
pourrait observer
moi j'ai plusieurs questions à vous
poser mais à mervans tout lorsque vous
parlez de morale laïque
je m'interroge parce que je suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse enseigner la morale
enseigné la morale ça voudrait dire
faire plutôt des sermons donc je pense
c'est peut-être plus intéressant
d'utiliser des disciplines pour faire
passer d'autres types de valeurs
républicaines et puis sur
l'apprentissage elle collège unique on
s'interrogera mais je pense que jean
claude carle vous vous posera des
questions à ce sujet moi j'ai plusieurs
questions la première question c'est
comment renforcer la transmission des
valeurs républicaines dans les
établissements scolaires est ce que le
contenu des enseignements et
l'organisation de la vie scolaire ou
saint dizant des établissements vous
semble-t-il adapté vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure de la difficulté d'enseigner
certaines disciplines si vous pouviez le
développer
et que pensez-vous à cet égard des
mesures annoncées par la ministre de
l'éducation nationale notamment sur non
seulement morale et civique qui sera mis
en place à la rentrée 2015
j'ai d'autres questions la deuxième
question où je vous laisse se répondre à
chaque question
ouais c'est peut-être aussi bien
je pose la voie de la deuxième question
juste après merci infiniment comme nous
sommes moins nombreux aujourd'hui du
fait du troisième tour des élections
départementales comme l'expliqué notre
présidente
voilà c'est aussi ça la république
important merci madame la présidente
j'avoue ma totale incompétence donc
peut-être vais-je perdre votre temps ma
totale incompétence en matière de
réflexion ou d'apport décisif s'agissant
de la transmission des valeurs
non pas que ce sujet ne m'intéresse pas
j'ai été enseignant moi même au collège
en lycée à l'université je trouve que
c'est un magnifique sujet ma conviction
mais qui est plus qu'une conviction se
dire que la situation globale du système
éducatif français tend malgré tout à
montrer que dès lors que vous faites
arrivé et d'ailleurs cette question
éclairent d'un jour nouveau
celle du collège unique décor que vous
faites arrivée en classe de 6ème de
façon répétée des cohortes qui à raison
de 20% maîtrisent mal la lecture
maîtrise man l'écriture maîtrise man du
calcul ne comprennent pas un texte
simple ne comprennent pas les objectifs
fixés par les enseignants vous pouvez
derrière à voir les plus beaux
programmes d'histoire l'éducation
civique de géographie de français vais
enseigner le code vous plus enseigner le
latin le grec
vous resterez entre 20 et 40% au fond la
capm accorte de ceux qui sont en
situation de très grandes difficultés de
20 % d'accord de ceux qui ont des acquis
fragiles et de 20% supplémentaires il
faut aussi accepter de regarder comme ça
c'est comme ça que pisanu présente
s'agissant en tout cas des performances
à 15 ans ont dès lors que vous avez une
cohorte aussi importante et que par
ailleurs cette corde vous savez bien
n'est pas disséminés sur le territoire
de façon égale sept corps tel est
concentré et concentré sur certains
établissements donc à une pèse
particulièrement sur certains des
collègues de l'éducation nationale qui
au fond se trouvent dans des
établissements qui vont cumuler toutes
les difficultés
je vois assez mal s'agissant de ses
élèves qui sont en très grande
difficulté qui de toute façon n'ont pas
d'amis
risque d'un texte notre ex simple je
vois assez mal ce que le changement d'un
programme
avec toutes les difficultés qu'on sait
avec toute la capillarité qui est aussi
nécessaire pour qu'arrive au bouddha de
la chaîne les différentes terminaisons
nerveuses terminaisons nerveuses pardon
les consignes ministérielles je vois
assez mal ce que va être l'impact de ce
type de mesures
je veux dire par là que cette question
ne fait assez fortement penser au débat
désormais récurrent tous les trois ans
quand paraît bizarre qui atteste que
l'école française est une école de la
défiance et liant une école les enfants
n'ont pas confiance alors est-ce que
c'est au fond la confiance ou cette
absence de confiance qui créent les
mauvais résultats
ou est ce que ce sont les mauvais
résultats qui crée cette absence de
défiance je pense pour ma part que
effectivement de mauvais résultats que
les enfants savent parfaitement
objective et s'ils sont dans des
fratries
ils ont des amis des voisins de palier
des cousins des cousines que les parents
savent très bien identifier
je pense que c'est tout simplement
d'abord et avant tout les mauvaises
performances qui crée ce sentiment de
défiance objectivée par enquêtes pisa
je vous renvoie également aux travaux de
yann algan et de pierre cahuc et me
semble utile tant qu'on ne sera pas
parvenu à fixer le problème de l'école
primaire
tant qu'on ne sera pas parvenu à un taux
fonds d'élèves en grande difficulté en
6ème plus proche de 5% ce qui quand même
pour une cinquième ou sixième pays le
plus riche du monde serait même mois
tout le reste ne sera que littérature
on voit bien qui bénéficiera
d'enseignement supplémentaires
socialement ça ira évidemment toujours à
ceux qui sont en mesure de les absorber
les absorberont soyez sans peine mais on
aura une fois de plus tiré avant de
viser et on aura manqué la cible
parce qu'on fait vraiment de réfléchir
de l'effet jours si on ne s'interroge
pas encore une fois en profondeur sur
les voies et moyens de faire diviser par
trois la grande difficulté à l'entrée du
collège etc c'est sans doute le meilleur
prédictif aujourd'hui d'une adhésion
d'une adhésion pardon plus forte aux
principes républicains et du vivre
ensemble
quant à la difficulté de certains types
d'enseignants moi je n'ai que la
connaissance de monsieur jourdain s'agit
semble cette difficulté
j'entends ce que me disent des recteurs
j'entends ce que me disent d aden on
sait bien que aujourd'hui s'agissant de
l'enseignement de l'histoire partiront
de la seconde guerre mondiale un certain
nombre d'épisodes peuvent plus ou moins
bien passé auprès de certains publics
je pense encore une fois que d'une
certaine façon ce qui compte d'abord et
avant tout c'est de bien montrer à
l'ensemble de ces petits français que
tout le monde avait même chance que les
chances sont également distribués sans
quoi on se retrouve dans des situations
qui sont situation qui nous renvoie pour
le coup assez loin dans notre histoire
qui sont les situation
prérévolutionnaire une deuxième question
peut-être que vous puissiez développer
parce que vous parliez tout à l'heure de
de valoriser le métier d'enseignant dans
le primaire en augmentant en augmentant
leur salaire est ce qu'il aurait pas
d'autres solutions peut-être sans
augmenter le salaire mais avec des
dédoublements de classes par ce coup là
il vous est bien pointer le doigt sur le
la difficulté des élèves de pouvoir lire
correctement comprendre des textes je
souhaiterais que développiez ça et puis
aussi il ya différents types de rapports
et les rapports d'ailleurs de l'institut
montaigne qui seul rapport obin ou le
rapport du hci qui montrent qu'ils ont
montré vous en avez parlé précédemment
sur la dilution de nombreux jeunes issus
de classes socio économique défavorisé
envers une république qu'ils estiment
inégalitaire alors quel rôle l'éducation
nationale vous en avait parlé en partie
mais qu'est ce qu'elle peut
véritablement faire dans ce contexte qui
est difficile et puis plus généralement
quelle mesure peut-être plus concrète
pour être mises en place pour lutter
contre ces dysfonctionnements de l'école
merci madame la présidente
aucune des sénateurs aucune des mesures
et nous y connaissons bien pour en avoir
déjà beaucoup discuté aucune des
des mesures prises isolément n'a
d'impact dire que ce qui est de l'impact
c'est d'abord et avant tout une vision
aussi je pense qu une des dernières fois
on est parvenu à inverser à la fois un
sentiment le sentiment du grand public a
parfois le sentiment des utilisateurs
sur les étudiants
celui des enseignants en matière de
réformes
s'agissant de l'éducation c'est la loi
de 2007 sur l'autonomie
pourquoi y en a fait une priorité
nationale parce que cette priorité c'est
un script dans un cadre réseau bus et
dans un cadre continue sur cinq ans
d'exercice d'un mandat donc je ne fais
pas ici je ne me fais pas le parangon de
cette foire on peut surtout de quoi et
vous savez sur tout texte législatif à
la fois s'interroger sur l'évaluation la
mise en oeuvre etc
il se trouve que je crois que de 2004 à
2007 a cristallisé en france une pensée
sur l'autonomie universitaire et que
cette pensée c'est intégrer un programme
présidentiel que ce programme
présidentiel a montré que au fond une
parole près électorale était suivie
d'effet sentiment que s'agissant de
l'école primaire on est un peu face au
même défi et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
savoir comment dire actionner tous les
leviers en même temps il y a neuf et le
biais de la rémunération et je pense que
c'est un levier important s'agissant du
primaire s'agissant par ailleurs deux
catégories de fonctionnaires que le
législateur a choisi faire de faire
recruter désormais à bac + 5
donc à un niveau de cadres donc il faut
être cohérent à un moment ou un autre
si on veut attirer les meilleurs d'une
génération vers ce métier il faut être
capable de leur dire qu'ils n'auront pas
les moins bonnes solaire de l'ensemble
des diplômés de même niveau
me semble utile s'agissant des
conditions de travail plutôt que de
parler dédoublement s'agissant des
conditions de travail vu effectivement
il faudrait avoir le courage de dire que
objectivement les conditions
d'enseignement au pied de la montagne
sainte geneviève ou même à son sommet
sont pas exactement les mêmes 4 ap
a clichy sous bois montfermeil est donc
apparemment ça nécessite sans doute de
mieux calibrer l'effort public en
matière de rééquilibrage des chances
mais troisième élément
je dis qu'il faudra tout faire de front
ce que demandent aujourd'hui des
enseignants ce sont des outils ce que
demandent aujourd'hui les enseignants
c'est qu'on les aide davantage en fixant
scientifiquement un certain nombre de
priorités en les déclinant sous forme
d'outils d'outils papier d'outils
numériques d'outils pédagogiques et que
ces outils leur permettent d'organiser
la progression des élèves les plus en
difficulté il n'y a pas de
fonctionnaires qui n'est pas envie de
voir sa performance s'améliorer ça
n'existe pas les fonctionnaires sont
comme les salariés du privé
ils ont envie de réussir leur mission et
c'est particulièrement vrai des
enseignants qui ont la plus belle des
missions à partir de là il faut aussi un
moment ou un autre que la communauté
nationale les entendent
moi je redis je pense qu'aujourd'hui des
enseignants du primaire sont mal
considérés trop peu rémunérés je pense
que il travaille dans les classes qui
sont trop importantes dans certains cas
pas dans d'autres
eu égard la mission qui leur est demandé
je pense qu'ils sont parfaitement
dépourvues d'outils faisons compte des
manuels aujourd'hui qui restent figées
30 ou 40 ans en arrière
à un moment on étions en plein en plein
milieu de guerre de religion sur sur des
visions pédagogique du monde qui était
complètement idéologisé de ce point de
vue blanc peut pas dire que l'édition
française se singularise par son goût
d'une grande qualité de ce qu'elle
produit aussi on pourrait re dire un
rapport un rapport de l'inspection
générale des finances et l'inspection
générale de l'éducation nationale nar a
pris avec trop peu de force à mon goût
et trop peu de reprise mais c'est un
secteur qui vivent de la rente et d'une
rente qu'il se corrige paquin appuyé sur
aucune recherche scientifique
quatrième point derrière les outils la
question effectivement de l'inclusion
des parents je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une timidité très forte
il ya une timide et très forte encore
d'établissements scolaires incluant les
parents je regarde quels effets
luc chatel et jean michel goulletquer au
titre de la mallette des parents je
regarde des violations l'école
d'économie de paris
quand je vois qu'un dispositif qui ne
coûte quasiment rien produit des effets
aussi important j'ai une envie comme à
la fois contribuables comme
fonctionnaire comme citoyen c'est de le
voir se déployer au maximum et partout
où on en a besoin et je pense que
particulièrement pour des parents qui
ont lu un rapport à eux mêmes difficiles
à l'école particulièrement pour des
parents qui n'ont pas été élevés dans le
système éducatif
il serait important que les codes sache
s'ouvrir de façon beaucoup plus forte
je ne parle pas de conseil
d'administration janas une une position
assez ferme
je pars effectivement d'un effort
véritable d'inclusion des parents dans
la salle de classe
je sais que d'ores et déjà j'ai parlé
pour le coup et vous m'en excuserez
d'établissement qui sont hors contrat
dans l'établissement montessori par
exemple quand des parents ne sont pas
eux-mêmes passer par la pédagogie
montessori
on propose assez régulièrement à ses
parents de passer deux heures trois
heures dans la classe un matin pour voir
comment on y travaille et ça me semble
très créateur de confiance de
transparence et de compréhension de ce
que sont les stratégies pédagogiques
déployés pour amener les enfants au
meilleur niveau
donc c'est tout cet ensemble qui est un
ensemble à la fois politiques publiques
qui est un ensemble culturel qui est un
ensemble juridique aussi qu'il faut
savoir pousser et sans week-end
objectivement nous n'arriverons pas
tellement aujourd'hui la situation de
non performance d' inégalités du système
est en piste et nous n'arriverons pas
dans un délai raisonnable à inverser la
courbe de nos performances
prenons la floride canjet bush est
parvenu à inverser les résultats d'un
certain nombre d'écoles de son état il
est parvenu à faire en cinq ans je cite
cette durée un peu au hasard mais elle
correspond à un cadre de réflexion qui
vous est cher il me semble absolument
nécessaire de rappeler que ce n'est pas
en expliquant des fonctionnaires qu'on
obtiendra des résultats dans huit ou dix
ans au prix de sacrifices immenses
commis un instant t conte et mobilise le
mieux en éducation il est faux de dire
que les résultats viennent après 10 15
ou 20 ans on peut obtenir des résultats
rapidement
j'espère avoir répondu musique sénateurs
à vos deux d'interrogation merci
beaucoup
si jean claude carle à qui on a demandé
de poser une question
ça s'appelle être sollicités chers
collègues donc nous écoutons vos
questions merci madame la présidente je
voudrais tout d'abord m'excuser auprès
de laurent bigorgne de n'avoir plus
écoutés c'est le début de ces propos
jettent était pourtant l'heure mais j'ai
fait une mauvaise rencontre dans les
couloirs du sénat
ce que je regrette c'est que monsieur
bigorne vous enseignez devant un
auditoire très prisé très éparses mais
s'est repris par le site du sénat donc
je pense que tout ce que vous venez de
dire un écho et je voudrais dire combien
je partage ce que vous venez de nous
dire et les axes que vous proposez les
acquis précoce pas c'est le gage de la
réussite quand on sait que l'avenir
scolaire d'un jeune quasiment scellé
quand il fait son septième anniversaire
que ça ça passe bien sûr par les des
pédagogies qui permettent justement aux
enseignants de pouvoir faire en sorte
que les élèves
je veux dire capte ses acquis et puis
troisième axe celui de l'apprentissage
ou là je suis tout à fait en phase avec
vous il ya qu un chiffre à prendre seco
chez nous le chômage des jeunes
récurrent depuis des décennies à 25 %
d'une classe d'âge c'est à dire que un
jeune au terme de ses études la première
porte qui l'a poussé c'est celle de pôle
emploi est ce pas celle d'une d'une
entreprise 7% seulement en allemagne
je crois qu'il n'y a pas besoin de d'en
dire plus alors vous nous avez dit que
si on respectait à ces trois axes en
2025 on réglerait le problème
après 2005 2015 2025
je souhaite que vous ayez raison je
crains que daredevil 25 à vous veniez
nous dire on ne sera plus là mais où
ceux ci que ans ont constaté le même le
même état de fait
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'il y
avait un gros problème de méthode et
qu'aujourd'hui si on ne change pas
l'organisation de notre système scolaire
notre un système éducatif
on aura des difficultés à faire évoluer
la situation tant les corporatismes de
tous bords sont forts et l'eau sont
autant de points indique effectivement
le primaire a été sous-traitée
sous-dotées plus tôt c'est tout à fait
vrai que les moyens ont été mis dans le
secondaire alors qu'ils étaient déjà
extrêmement abondant je crois que l'une
des raisons il ya plusieurs raisons mais
la première raison c'est le poids des
corporatismes ne faut pas se le cacher
et je dis bien des corporatismes de de
tous bords à commencer par le
corporatisme centrale de la rue de
bonnel express qu'il faut pas là inquiet
une modification profonde de ceux de
l'organisation de 1,2 de pyramidale
aujourd'hui de l'éducation nationale
nous avons fait une commission
d'information l'époque sur
l'organisation territoriale de
l'éducation nationale et on voit bien
que tous les expérimentations qui sont
faites qui partent de la base ça marche
tout ce qui est imposé par la rue de
grenelle à des difficultés
à mettre en place tant je voulais
d'éléphants gens voir alors est-ce que
c'est pas ma première question est ce
que c'est pas au niveau de la méthode de
l'organisation qu'il faut j'allais dire
porter l'effort sur les objectifs
sachant que tout le monde à peu près il
ya un consensus pour dire que ça ne
pourra pas continuer de la sorte
merci beaucoup
les raisons je pense que vous avez
raison je pense que au final ce qui est
assez frappant quand on regarde la rue
de grenelle qui recèle aussi trésors
d'inventivité jeu utilise en s'en
vouloir
caresser dans le sens du poil mais il ya
aussi des gens très bien pris
individuellement mais il ya au fond une
incapacité aujourd'hui accolé à une
école dont les besoins ont changé
je pense par exemple qu'il est
déraisonnable et on avait une expérience
de ne pas donner davantage d'autonomie à
une direction comme la dette aujourd'hui
qui devrait devenir la direction du big
data et de l'open data dans l'éducation
nationale et qui pourrait très bien
vivre demain je n'ai pas la passion ni
des agents en eas opérateurs les
autorités administratives indépendantes
mais je trouve qu'un gage de
transparence tant que système serait de
permettre demain adeptes de devenir une
autorité administrative indépendante
bien sûr aux services du ministère mais
rendant compte au moins une fois par an
au parlement de la situation des coop de
la situation de ces personnels de la
situation dans les territoires de la
situation pour chaque maire pour chaque
aiguë pour chaque président d'exécutif
territoriale de la situation objective
des résultats dans les circonscriptions
concernées
je pense qu'un enjeu très fort quand un
système semble bloquée à pouvoir allumer
de la lumière aussi utilisons analogie
de l'enseignement supérieur les pays qui
ont réussi de très belles transitions en
matière d'enseignement supérieur je
prends notamment cas de la
grande-bretagne
je vais pousser le bouchon très loin
mais il se trouve qu'en grande bretagne
ils ont fait disparaître le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur ce que je ne
suis pas venu vos propos
de faire ce matin mais ils ont d'abord
et avant tout créer une agence
d'évaluation qui aujourd'hui au final
être extraordinairement importante dans
le dispositif fiscal dit ce qu'est la
qualité du dispositif à l'échelle macro
et à l'échelle micro il me paraît
absolument important effectivement que
cette responsabilité soit portée par une
date très fort très indépendante et dont
au fond les deux assemblées seraient les
principaux clients en matière
d'évaluation des politiques publiques
c'est là mon avis une des premières
choses à faire mais deuxième chose
parler des corporatismes et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne précise plus
suffisamment qu'il allait mission d
inspection générale et on voit des
inspecteurs généraux à la fois dans une
mission d'inspection parfois dans une
mission de réalisation c'est un vivier
pour les cabinets c'est un vivier pour
l'administration centrale ça me paraît
une situation un peu problématique
ça me paraît être une situation au fond
vous dire que vos organisations la
séparation des pouvoirs n'est pas
toujours correctement assurée c'est
aussi une administration qui se
renouvellent assez peu avant même que
des compétences en matière d'inspection
pourrait être expérimentée dans d'autres
ministères pourrait très bien imaginer
que ses inspecteurs généraux et plus
souvent regarder ce qui se passe à bercy
au ministère de l'emploi ministère des
affaires sociales on pourrait très bien
imaginer que cette capacité à ne pas
rester
jalili renfermé trop longtemps le
grenelle il ya deux inspections
aujourd'hui à l'éducation nationale
c'est au moins une de trop je pense
qu'il faut fusionner ces corps
d'inspection le plus rapidement possible
et puis recalé bien les missions pour
que tout simplement
cette inspection serbes le ministre
serbe des directions concernées
plutôt que d'être aujourd'hui sans doute
de façon un peu troublante
eu égard au fonctionnement démocratique
une espèce d'état dans l'état et je
pense que par ailleurs une fois qu'on a
fait ça il faut doter l'état à très haut
niveau sur des bases extraordinairement
exigeante
il faut doter l'état d'un conseil
scientifique et stratégique
où les meilleurs chercheurs du pays ce
qu'ils publient monsieur le sénateur ce
qu'ils publient dans des revues
internationales pas les autres je le dis
avec beaucoup de gravité mais parce que
je pense qu'en médecine on n'accepterait
pas une situation contraire donc
pourquoi accepter pour nos enfants ou
ceux qui publient auront droit de cité
si en matière de gouvernance on est déjà
capable et voyez ce que je dessine là ça
n'est pas une révolution c'est une
évolution normale acquise au fond
impactés par ce qu'est la situation
je crois que cette évolution de
gouvernance cette évolution de
transparence est très nécessaire
c'est une assemblée comme la vôtre qui
peut aussi la porte et qui peut à
manifester ma place des scientifiques
nous recalage des missions d'inspection
la création d'une grande mission d'une
grande autorité administrative
indépendante en matière de big data et
d'open data dans l'éducation c'est
quelque chose dont nous avons besoin
parce que c'est là dessus que vous
pourrez prendre appui vous législateur
c'est là dessus pour apprendre à puis
exécutif
tout simplement pour faire progresser le
système sur des bases objectives neutre
et où effectivement le jeu des acteurs
est un peu recalés moi j'ai été frappée
je vous dis ayant participé à la
concertation de 2012 sur la refondation
de l'école de voir que je n'ai rien
contre eux 20 mai que telle ou telle
association d'enseignants pour la
défense de l'environnement voire
atlantique avaient le même poids dans
les débats que michel fayolle le patron
des sciences psycho cognitives de la nr
et j'ai été frappée pourquoi pas par
condescendance ou mépris je pense que il
est bon d'entendre toutes les parades
mais on ne le ferai jamais dans le
domaine médical
si on parlait du traitement du cancer
mais jamais on ne donnerait une même
poids un des meilleurs chercheurs
nationaux et internationaux et à une
association dont l'objet est louable
mais en même temps pas premiers par
rapport à la con street et donc il ya
aussi un moment où on peut se dire que
s'agissant tout simplement de l'avenir
de notre pays et de nos enfants on a le
droit d'avoir le même type de prévention
nous même type d'appréhension et donc le
même type au fond de décision de
caractère raisonnable
la façon dont doit s'élaborer un débat
public construit en matière
d'organisation effectivement des mesures
assez simple j ajoute
me paraît assez invraisemblable
qu'aujourd'hui me vivier de recrutement
des recteurs continue de se concentrer
sur une base extraordinairement étriqué
j'ai extraordinairement de respect pour
cette corporation ayant travaillé très
longtemps dans l'enseignement supérieur
mais qui est celle des universitaires il
peut y avoir des universitaires
merveilleux comme recteur
mais on peut aussi se dire qu'une
administration aussi importante que
l'éducation nationale a eu droit à de
devoir d'élargir ses viviers de
recrutement
je suis vraiment frappé de ce quasi
monopole quand les universitaires sur
les carrières rectorat il me paraît on
va me dire oui mais on va ouvert c'est
déjà possible une mais ça n'arrive pas
donc si ça n'arrive pas c'est qu'il ya
des blocages et il appartient de
souligner que ces blocages
au final empêche le renouvellement
pasche l'oxygénation de ce corps et je
pense que c'est un de nos problèmes tant
les champs rectorat particulièrement
dans le cadre des différents projets de
revue de la décentralisation qui sont
discutées en ce moment ce job va être
éminemment important pour inconduite
fine du paysage éducatif territoire par
territoire
donc je pense qu'on a là un vrai sujet
je pense que honnêtement nous recteur
aujourd'hui de seine-saint-denis il a 80
mille enseignants sa responsabilité ne
recteur de versailles en a 100 mines on
peut imaginer qu'il ya un certain nombre
dont on parlera d'administration énorme
on peut imaginer que des hauts
fonctionnaires venus d'autres
administrations et on peut imaginer que
des gens ayant un autre vécu pourquoi
pas y ont fait une partie de leur
carrière dans le privé tout en ayant une
bonne connaissance du secteur public
puisse exercer demain ses
responsabilités y apporter des pratiques
et apporter une vision particulièrement
là où l'enjeu est celui du noeud entre
système éducatif et systèmes productifs
on peut imaginer que d'autres
compétences soit à portée de main bien
que encore une fois ne pas regarder ce
problème
de ce qu'est la sociologie électorale
aujourd'hui me pose problème
s'agissant encore une fois d'entités qui
sont des entités très importante
ajoutons que s'agissant des oeufs
d'académie dont j'ai parlé ce sont les
châteaux d'eau du recrutement des profs
en france c'est par définition les
enseignants à versailles et enfin tout
cas dans l'académie de versailles à
101,10 sont extraordinairement jeune
donc on a intérêt à concentrer nos
efforts pour convaincre les meilleurs
d'entre eux de rester dans cette
carrière pour convaincre ces jeunes gens
mais de j'allais dire ces jeunes profs
de toujours ou titre d'information
préfinale faire mieux chercher à
atteindre un meilleur niveau on a
intérêt à les inciter on a donné on a
intérêt à ordonner des figures de
réussite et il me semble et y voilà ce
n'est pas exactement
et ça n'a rien de personnel un directeur
qu'on a aujourd'hui son formidable mais
je dis juste qu'on a à un moment ou un
autre besoin de cette réflexion sur la
sociologie du personnel qu'on recrute
pour exercer ce type de responsabilités
ça contribuerait grandement à
l'ouverture de ce ministère merci à
wimbly sur vas-y vas-y que je voulais je
voulais juste su réagir parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a on a auditionné quelques
recteurs et on se sent bien
véritablement que c'est un système
endémique qui s'auto génère et je crois
que vous avez raison de dire qu'il faut
apporter un peu de fraîcheur et puis
l'ouverture sous d'autres s'en remettre
en question tout à fait vous avez raison
de le dire les personnes qui sont des
personnes de qualité mais ça apporterait
beaucoup et je voudrais juste faire une
petite précision pour l'inspection
générale lorsque je vois le mode de
recrutement aussi de l'inspection
générale et puis le l'orientation
politique qui peut être donnée aussi par
certains par certains doyens je
m'interroge aussi sur le bien fondé de
cette structure là je pense qu'il faudra
aussi réfléchir sur une notre mode
d'organisation et je pense que
l'inspection générale je peux le dire la
même si c'est repris je pense que
quelque part elle a vécu je me faire des
amis
porter pour ses propos très clair et
franc
ça fait sourire et rebondir notre
collègue jean claude carle allez-y
tout à fait puisque j'avais fait cette
proposition il y à quelques il y a
quelques années sur le social rôle du
parlement c'est vrai qu'il faut que nous
prenions nos responsabilités
1 c'est pas acceptable que le parlement
passe seulement deux heures par an 3
heures par an assure les problèmes
éducatifs notamment à l'occasion de la
discussion du budget 63 milliards
discuter en deux ou trois heures
on met on consacre autant dans pour les
budgets des monnaies et médailles
je crois que l'éducation c'est quand
même plus important et c'est tellement
important que je pense qu'effectivement
il faut pas la laisser au seul monde de
l'éducation et je vais revenir sur la
maternelle dont vous avez dit
l'important c'est l'absence justement
dans certaines zones des zones rurales
ou des zones urbaines en difficulté
est ce que il n'y aurait pas une mesure
qui finalement est inscrite dans la loi
jospin 89,1 qui était de racoler
d'accoler pardon le
la dernière année de maternelle à au cp
et aux crs qui rendrait de fait
obligatoire la scolarité de cette
dernière année de maternelle est ce que
ce serait pas j'allais dire une solution
qui pourrait être mis en place
et puis troisième question concernant
l'évaluation c'est vrai que le système
souffre d' évaluation sérieuse ya des
évaluations mais qui sont faites par
ceux qui sont juges et parties etc sont
souvent des dévaluations je veux pas
dire de complaisance mais qui ont pas je
veux dire une grande valeur alors est ce
que il faut que le système
faut-il que le système d'évaluation
reste à l'intérieur du système éducatif
ou qui est une agence indépendante 1 qui
pourrait évaluer l'éducation nationale
mais aussi d'autres corps de du secteur
public qui souffrent de la même chose la
cour des comptes
souvent l'occasion de le dire dans ces
rapports si vous voulez bien dépendre
merci à ma présidente
je partage votre point sur même
nécessaire précocité notamment pour les
publics les plus en difficulté d'une
mise en milieu scolaire la plus rapide
possible la plus précoce possible
je lisais ce matin avant de venir vous
retrouvé un papier de bruno suchaut kir
après une étude américaine de 2004 qui
explique bien qu'à trois ans un enfant
issu de milieux défavorisés est en
déficit d'une trentaine de millions de
mots par rapport à un enfant élevé dans
un milieu favorisé
c'est à dire que trentaine de millions
de mots entendus de me répéter
et donc mes exercices fait par son
cerveau tout simplement les interactions
langagière ont développé évidemment ses
capacités cognitives infiniment plus que
l'enfant qui est placé dans une
situation où les interactions sont très
pauvres
les réactions sont à venir insuffisante
pour emmener à ce que vont être les
compétences de près lecture et derrière
évidemment une acquisition de la lecture
on a dans les années 80 scolarisé
jusqu'à 35% de la population vous savez
à l'âge de deux ans on a reflué depuis
et je leur dise de scolarisation à 2 ans
n'est pas en soi pas suffisante mais
pour certains publics
elle est absolument nécessaire elle est
absolument décisif encore faut-il qu'on
accepte que ce soit d'abord et avant
tout les outils de simulation engage
hier qui viennent nourrir le contenu des
activités proposées aux enfants qu'est
la vraie différence entre une crèche
aujourd'hui française ou une crèche d'un
pays d'europe du nord
ce sont les interactions il est temps
dans l'interaction les temps
d'engagements des petits avec les
animateurs les animatrices de ses
services si vous mettez les enfants et
qu'au final on est dans une simple
logique gérer dire qui est norman qui
est naturel qui doit préexister de
bienveillance mais pas dans une logique
de préapprentissage vous aurez à la fois
dépenser beaucoup d'argent et obtenu peu
de résultats et c'est pour ça que il m'a
semblé nécessaire je sais que vous
entendez ce matin michel lussault mais
de rappeler que programmes de grande
section le succès nateur devez
impérativement comporter conserver le
maximum d'éléments possible s'agissant
des apprentissages cognitifs et des
compétences de près lecture dire que
qu'on est envisagée en 2014 pouvoir
vider et c'était une pensée qui est pas
mal venu de l'inspection générale
monsieur le sénateur qu'on est envisagé
pouvoir vider une partie du programme de
grande section d apprentissage cognitif
notamment de la phonologie au motif que
c'est une violence faite aux enfants me
paraît à la fois un fondée
scientifiquement très fondé
idéologiquement et porteur d'une
dégradation des résultats de notre
système public d'un système éducatif à
court et moyen termes absolument
catastrophique
je suis assez content que encore une
fois je l'aï dit tout à l'heure et je le
redis créé ministre ait mis fin à ces
débats et mis fin à cette espèce de
spéculation qui encore une fois n'est
conforme à aucun article scientifique
à aucune revue de littérature
scientifique qu'on pourrait trouver
auprès des meilleurs centres de
recherche universités du monde
voilà pour cette audition sur le thème
de l'éducation et la perte de repères
républicain vous avez vu les sénateurs
recevait laurent bigorgne président du
think tank libéral
l'institut montaigne devant les
sénateurs il est revenu sur sa vision du
système éducatif français et ses
solutions face à la crise que nous
traversons aujourd'hui c'est une
audition ne pouvait voir et revoir en
vod sur notre site publicsenat.fr dans
quelques instants
vous avez rendez vous avec delphine
girard pour votre journal le 24 heures
sénat très bonne suite des programmes
sur les chaînes parle